well joining us now to talk more about
cities of the future is the architect
michele pro tulip from the university of
applied sciences in pond stem he's also
been working for years on his own vision
for the city of the future welcome to
the show Michel much all right now how
realistic is the model that we saw in
the piece as a concept for a vertical
city of the future I think it's works as
an architectural object and it stands in
a tradition of architectural or token
thinking like Lacaze are the Japanese
metabolic approaches or powerlessly in
the United States but I won't think
that's was working in an area like it
was shown in the piece and in France or
in a landscape okay why not I think it
makes sense in a dance and environment
like in London Tokyo New York to build
high-rise buildings because of the
economic pressure I don't think that
people would prefer to live in a
vertical City if they have the landscape
the garden just in front of them why
right right it seems like it would be
very isolated existence in a structure
like that so having said that what is
your idea of a model city of the future
I believe that cities have to become
more self-sufficient mm-hmm there they
need to to be very energy-efficient
low-carbon the key word climate adaptive
30 scissors the real problem and also
the the water and the nutrient cycles in
the city they they need to be closed
okay is this something you're working on
yes I think the infrastructure is the
orb infrastructure there are many people
are working there many concepts existing
and prototypes and it needs to be them
improved and implemented in the existing
cities all right well tell us a little
bit more about these concepts these
other concepts for cities of the future
well for example you can use a different
system you can collect the the black
water waste the wastewater yeah and and
change it to
to energy and still you with the the
waist then for for the fields as a
fertilizer mm-hmm so you your clothing
the material cycle that's I think is
essential for the sustainability of
cities okay um are you familiar with the
term urban sprawl you know that's when
when cities begin to spread out quite a
bit how our city planners and architects
like yourself handling this issue of
urban sprawl well the reason for the
urban sprawl is or the opportunity is
that we have cheap energy resources if
energy becomes more expensive the
density of city will increase so I think
that has people or urban planners have
to to address that people want to live
in a green healthy environment at the
same time they want to be close in the
city and to have public transport
systems electron mobility is some thing
they're working on new modes of mutti
modality mm-hmm so fidgety moving it
towards a more clean environment clean
cities seems like the future we show up
or tula we thank you very much for this
discussion today thank you very much